according to documents obtained by the
website byline investigates
dano hanks was paid 2055
for this comprehensive report on megan
and her family
in 2016 including megan's phone number
addresses and social security number it
also
included details on her family hank says
he
almost wanted to cry watching the oprah
interview and says quote
i never wanted to cause meghan markle
harm and wouldn't have done the job if
i'd known
it would lead to all these problems i
also wanted to take this opportunity to
apologize to the queen
because i realized the harm of what i
did
the sun's publisher says hanks was not
tasked to do anything illegal
harry and megan who have often battled
the uk tabloids
were quick to respond to the private
investigators claims condemning what
they called the media's predatory
practices
and calling for a moment of reflection
we all know what the british press can
be like
and it was destroying my mental health
prince harry
hates the paparazzi understandably so
he blames them for his mother's death
but
here they are and they are the biggest
celebrities on the planet right now
[Music]
you